[Musique]
bonjour à tous donc nous consacrons
l'émission d'aujourd'hui diffusé en même
temps sur la bourgogne et la
franche-comté un débat de l'entre-deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle
élection présidentielle dont le second
tour a lieu dimanche prochain le 7 mai
les deux finalistes sont donc marine le
pen pour le front national et emmanuel
macron pour en marche
nous avons donc ici sur ce plateau tout
d'abord sophie montel du front national
elle soutient bien sûr marine le pen
elle est présidente du groupe fn au
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté
face à elle le bourguignon jean yves
caullet mère d'avalon député socialiste
de l'yonne qui soutient lui emmanuel
macron alors n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez réagir sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment sur twitter grâce au hashtag
dit mme paule belle s'est dit mme paul
comme dimanche en politique
fbfc comme bourgogne franche comté a
tout de suite première partie pour
entrer dans le vif du débat je vous
propose déjà de jeter un oeil aux
résultats qu'ils ont eu lieu dont qui se
sont produits sur la bourgogne franche
comté dimanche dernier au premier tour
marine le pen est arrivée largement en
tête dans notre région à la moyenne
régionale c'est 25% pour les faits
beaucoup plus qu'en france où elle est à
21,3 et puis après donc c'est emmanuel
macron à presque 22 % françois fillon
19,7 et jean luc mélenchon 17,9 et puis
je vous laisse découvrir les scores des
autres candidats
arrivait ensuite en bourgogne franche
comté alors sophie montel
j'étais avec vous dimanche dernier donc
à votre qg du front national à besançon
je vous ai senti un petit peu déçu par
les résultats notamment les résultats
nationaux
parce que vous pensez que marine le pen
allait arriver première est beaucoup
beaucoup plus haut que ce qui est arrivé
vraiment dimanche dernier oui mais vous
savez quand on est dans une élection et
notamment une élection présidentielle
qui est l'élection mer on aspire
toujours un résultat toujours plus le
plus élevé possible
ceci étant et la réelle
c'est un très très bon score au niveau
national la place d'outsider est une
très très bonne place et puis le score
réalisé par marine en bourgogne franche
comté est un score un score exceptionnel
un score qui est toujours en dynamique
d'ailleurs depuis 2012 nous nous
inscrivons dans cette dynamique
élection après élection déjà yvonig et
que marine le pen est en tête on va le
voir sur une carte dans donc la majeure
partie des départements de bourgogne
franche comté ya que la côte d'or qui a
placé emmanuel macron en tête des
sondages dimanche dernier jean yves
caullet et quelle est votre réaction
face à ce premier tour je pense que avec
emmanuel macron qui n'arrive en tête que
dans la côte d'or vous avez été un peu
déçu mais j'ai goûté ils arrivent en
tête au niveau national ce qui est quoi
une belle 7 6 6 4 à votre bonheur
écoutez vu les pronostics qui était
annoncé que vous avez rappelé plaçant
marine le pen en tête etc
je pense que c'est un très bon signal
pour ce qui concerne la bourgogne
franche comté effectivement marine le
pen est en tête mais avec un recul de
près de 7 points par rapport aux
régionales et malgré une participation
en hausse
un tout petit gain de 10 mille voix ce
qui montre bien qu'il y a quand même une
possibilité d'un second tour très
dynamique y compris en bourgogne franche
comté et bien justement va aborder la
deuxième partie de cette émission le
l'entre-deux-tours la campagne
[Musique]
alors cette première semaine de
l'entre-deux tours a été riche en
événements à gauche jean luc mélenchon
n'a pas de donné de consignes claires et
c'est un événement à droite les
républicains ont appelé à faire barrage
à l'extrême droite en appelant à voleter
emmanuel macron et puis vendredi grande
nouvelle marine le pen et nicolas dupont
aignan debout la france se marie sophie
montel est ce que vous êtes ravi est ce
que c'est une chance supplémentaire de
victoire pour vous dimanche prochain
comment vous avez vécu ça on l'a vécu
une manière très positive
c'est une chance effectivement ça
augmente les chances de l'emporter au
soir du 7 mai et ça montre surtout que
le front républicain est mort cette
volonté qui étaient systématiquement
mises en place par nos adversaires elle
est qu'est ce que cela va s'arranger
aussi pour vous jouer la carte de
lentilles système visait ni mes amis et
bien attaquer nous sommes toujours être
attaqué par sommes toujours et tout ça
mais nous sommes toujours hors système
d'ailleurs nous le voyons à l'occasion
du ralliement de nicolas dupont aignan
le déferlement de haine sur les réseaux
sociaux de déclarations de gens du
showbiz outrancière d'une vulgarité sans
nom où monsieur dupont aignan se fait
traiter de tous les noms et nous sommes
en face dans cette campagne électorale
dans cette élection présidentielle ce
qui est très important c'est de vision
totalement totalement différentes qui
s'affrontent il ya d'abord d'un côté
on fait passer on va en parler ensuite
on va déjà faire réagir si ça vous
dérange pas monsieur collet quand vous
avez vu nicolas dupont aignan au côté de
marine le pen
quelle a été votre réaction vous allez
dire aussi le front républicain c'est
terminé non je pense que la droite
française si vous voulez un pendant des
décennies essayer de pactiser avec les
idées du front national et quand on met
un piment dans la soupe c'est pas le
piment qui prend le goût de soupe
donc ils ont organisé une perméabilité
avec les idées de l'extrême droite elle
se concrétise aujourd'hui pour des
raisons assez matériel à mon avis pour
monsieur nicolas dupont aignan qui a du
mal à financer sa campagne
et pour ce qui concerne les insultes la
violence et de la vulgarité vos amis
sont d'une telle inventivité sur les
réseaux sociaux que je vous en laisse la
primeur
la réponse par rapport aux problèmes de
financement de nicolas dupont aignan en
scène je leur amène d'avoir dépassé les
5%
donc ne voit pas ses frais de campagne
présidentielle pas dans la tambouille
électorale on laisse ça au parti
socialiste et à ses alliés et au nouveau
parti dirigé par monsieur maquereau en
marche qui n'est rien d'autre qu'un
recyclage alors on voit tous les
soutiens de monsieur macron sonder les
vieux de la vieille sont les dinosaures
de la politique française que ce soit
ceux qui viennent de la droite ou du
parti socialiste qui se coalisent autour
de monsieur macron pour mener en fait la
même politique qui ruinent le pays
depuis une trentaine d'années comme on
parle de l'entre-deux-tours donc au
premier tour marine le pen fait un peu
plus de 21% pour être élue présidente de
la république
même avec les 4,7 pour cent de nicolas
dupont aignan il manque quand même des
voix ou est ce que vous pensez aller les
trouver
on va les récupérer partout c'est ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure nous
sommes en face dans cette élection
présidentielle nous avons deux visions
qui s'opposent
il y a une volonté très nette qui s'est
dégagée durant le premier tour c'est l
enseignement du premier tour de cette
élection présidentielle c'est une
volonté de rupture avec le système c'est
une volonté de rupture avec cette
oligarchie avec cette haute finance avec
avec tous ces gens du showbiz avec tous
ces gens qui dirige le pays depuis une
trentaine d'années qu'ils sont copains
comme cochons qui ce qui en fait ont
mené le pays droit dans le mur on le
voit aujourd'hui on sort d'un
quinquennat socialistes jamais construit
la socialiste
on va en retour on va trouver des vous
apparaissez les abstentionnistes ceux
qui ont voté pour monsieur fillon ceux
qui ont voté pour monsieur mélenchon
parce que les gens ont une réelle
volonté de rupture avec le système de la
mondialisation avec 7,7 politique qui
est mise en place depuis notamment les
cinq dernières années où on ne protège
plus le taux de chômage a explosé la
sécurité a explosé donc les français
veulent vraiment une nouvelle façon de
faire la politique et veulent être
protégé monsieur collet première chose
la réaction ou la non consignes devaient
être des gens dit mélenchon vous en
pensez quoi
je porte je pense que jean luc mélenchon
en l'occurrence ne représente que lui
même et que les gens qui ont voté pour
lui feront le tri entre les deux projets
d'aujourd'hui mais pour ce qui concerne
si vous les deux on va aller chercher
des voix partout je comprend
effectivement pourquoi le programme de
madame le pen varient pourquoi monsieur
dupont-aignan qui n'avait pas de mots
assez durs pour son programme tout d'un
coup le trouve très bien pourquoi vous
voulez sortir de l'euro sur fond n'en
sort plus mais en sortir effectivement
on essaye de faire une politique d'att
rapetou et dans ce message mais ça ne
s'est pas de bouger 40 ans vous êtes en
état mental
la mise en forme est sûre que les
européens la mise hors jeu de la france
au niveau économique et vous ne
tromperez pas la situation actuelle la
reconnaît missions qu'il est demandé par
le peuple français c'est celle au tour
d' emmanuel macron qui veut dépasser de
vieux clivage est parmi les plus vieux
c'est extrême droite sont les meilleurs
cycle en t il faut absolument que nous
arrivions à mettre ensemble ceux qui
veulent travailler pour le pays
vous savez très bien que c'est ce que
nous faisons dans nos collectivités
c'est ce que nous faisons dans n'importe
quelle entreprise
quelle association sportive et même en
famille on fait des choses
indépendamment de ces avis
la france joue les héris le
rassemblement des progrès mais pour ces
manuels macro n'a pas célébré un peu
vite sa victoire dimanche soir avec ses
petits dîners dans à peine un an
d'existence qui est en tête d'une
élection majeure mérite quand même un
petit coup de chapeau à ceux qui l'ont
soutenu et kiev qui ont fait une
campagne remarquable et il ne faut pas
voir plus loin
que cela les manifestations de joie bien
légitime pour un résultat qui appelle
celui du 2ème trop large possible alors
pour rebondir sur ce que dit ce film
ont-elles donc vous prenez le
renouvellement ll a dit que donc les
soutiens des manuels mâcon c'était des
vieux de la vieille vous vous êtes
socialiste au départ vous avez 60 ans
que vous avez fait plusieurs mandats
actuellement vous êtes député
est-ce que vous pensez que le
renouvellement doit passer forcément par
des gens comme vous où il faut trouver
un mix entre les anciens la disposition
de mon pays de ma collectivité si je
peux servir je servirai si d'autres le
font mieux que moi j'espère qu'ils
seront plus jeunes parce que c'est ça le
renouvellement faut pas mettre les
destins personnels en avant de tout ça
et j'ai été député sept ans dans toute
ma vie professionnelle ça fait 40 ans
que travail moi je ne suis pas un
professionnel je laisse ça à d'autres
très bien je vous propose maintenant de
passer à la troisième partie les thèmes
justement de cet entre-deux tours
[Musique]
donc il reste un peu plus de 16 minutes
dans cette émission et j'aimerais que
nous parlions des programmes respectifs
de vous candidat et qu'on voit bien
justement où il y as clivage entre
emmanuel macron et puis marine le pen
on va d'abord parlé de l'europe et de la
mondialisation
en quoi est-ce que emmanuel macron
pourquoi nous présente il l'europe et la
mondialisation comme une chance pour la
france et pour français alors que l'on
voit tous les ravages qui sont commis
par la mondialisation notamment dans nos
industries
tout simplement parce que la
mondialisation est un fait on ne peut
pas être pour contre elle existe et ce
n'est pas la france tout seul qui va
dicter à la chine à l'inde à la russie
aux etats-unis au brésil
le fait de ne pas être mondialisation et
que dans cette compétition
soit on est dans la compétition il faut
la jouer avec l'équipe européenne pour
peser le même poids que les autres ou
alors on se met hors jeu on faire nos
frontières c'est un peu comme un
commerçant qui fermerait boutique en
attendant le client
ça ne fonctionnera pas nous devons être
fiers de la france lui redonner sa place
innover investir fort mais c'est comme
ça qu au sein de l'europe
nous gagnerons
la compétition internationale votre la
vision de marine le pen et du front
national est totalement inverse
moi je suis d'accord sur un point avec
le chiot collet nous sommes
effectivement dans un monde dans une
globalisation dans un monde de la
mondialisation
ceci étant nous ce que nous souhaitons
faire monsieur collet parce que vous
nous faites le bilan vous ne faîtes ce
que ce que vous ne faites pas c'est le
bilan des politiques menées par l'union
européenne qui vend qui vont vers plus
de dérégulation de flexibilité on le
verra peut-être tout à l'heure quand on
enlève quand on parlera t on pas l'union
européenne on verra peut-être tout à
l'heure quand on parla de la loi il
comme riz si vous voulez bien ce que
nous voulons nous s'est réarmé la france
lui redonner des outils pour se protéger
pour protéger ses industries pour
protéger son économie on est quand même
et puis pour se protéger d'un danger
d'un fléau qui est un fléau
extraordinairement dangereux qui
s'appelle le terrorisme le
fondamentalisme islamiste
on a en les français sont conscients des
dégâts de la mondialisation ils sont
aussi conscients de votre inaction 10
l'inaction du quinquennat sous monsieur
hollande et des politiques néfastes qui
ont été mises en place totalement
inspiré par les directives européennes
il faut que nos compatriotes nos
compatriotes le savent d'ailleurs 80%
des lois qui sont votées à l'assemblée
nationale sont des directives
européennes qui sont transcrites en
droit français
moi je sais pas en quoi vous allez
protégées notamment par exemple les
retraités quand j'entends emmanuel
macron dire qu'il va augmenter la csg de
1,7 pour cent sont le monsieur monsieur
pisani qui a fait le programme
économique de monsieur macron à lui est
membre reconnu que 60 % des retraités
allait dorénavant payer la cg donc sa
vague rêver directement leur pouvoir
d'achat en expliquant d'ailleurs que le
retraité en france avait il a enfin on
parle de l'europe
c'est une c'est une c'est alors juste
par exemple y est quand même répondre à
l'essai programmes des manuels macro
qu'il est prévu d'augmenter le minimum
vieillesse dont vous ne dit absolument
rien alors que ça concerne les plus
faibles parmi les recrues et il est
prévu d'augmenter les salaires net via
lirai plus s'exonérer de la taxation sur
80 qui va payer le contribuable et que
devient madame motel est ce que vous
laissez
7 vous tendrons après la csg que vous
mettez en exergue est largement
compensée par toutes les mesures que je
viens de citer
et la seule catégorie qui possède brille
certes être les calculs entre 500 euros
de taxe d'habitation et 1,7 pour cent de
csg ya pas photo on rase ya pas photo et
vous avez-vous essayé à fouler les gens
me mettent voilà la panique comme vous
le faites toujours vous travaillez sur
la peur la rupture est dû sur le repli
sur soi ça n'est pas l'avenir de riz
frontières monsieur coller ce ne sont
pas des murs ce sont des filtres vous
savez c'est comme la peau ça permet de
respirer en même temps ça permet de
protéger l'organisme
voilà et bien je dois vous annoncer leur
aux frontières de l'action où chaque
fois qu'il omet les questions au
parlement votait qu'on connait se
mesurent leur ensemble ne suis pas pour
la supranationalité monsieur koné je
veux retrouver mes souveraineté est
juste mais c'est bien on ferme et on la
voit le votre union européenne c'est un
échec dans tous les domaines 95% des
pays dans le monde ont des frontières
canada gaz pour cent des pays dans le
monde des nations
j'aimerais 2002 oloron non non ça où on
en sort parmi eux c'était ma question ne
saurait nous voulons revenir à une
monnaie mais j'ai pas compris le lièvre
vous ne fait pas les bus mais sur vous
et moi hier qu'est ce qui s'est passé
entre marine le pen et nicolas
dupont-aignan s'est pas claire parce que
maintenant il ya un euro à douala
tombeau il est au piquet nous pas du
tout nous sommes toujours dans la
volonté de renégocier de négocier avec
l'union européenne pour récupérer notre
4nous 4 souveraineté souveraineté
monétaire souveraineté budgétaire
souveraineté législatives et sortir de
chez niel pour peu qu'on associe euros
pour les anti suisse monsieur collet
l'euro a dévalué en deux ans de 25%
est-ce que les épargnants pour autant
ont vu leur épargne d'évaluer dans les
importations ça du tout et puis la
dévaluation c'est très bon pour
l'exportation oui ou oui c'est moins bon
pour les emprunts de la france qui sont
libellés en euros et qui semble avoir
fait cuire une pulsion libellés en droit
français à 90 euros
rouag oui encore sous droit français
vous savez ce que c'est que la lex
manhattan non j'ai besoin d'un
professeur comme vous ça va oui ben oui
mais quand on voit les résultats b à la
pompe à la pompe les français verraient
mais ils ne le verront pas car il est
évident qu'on retravaille est
catastrophique au pouvoir français l'air
sql l'habitude l'explosion des tarifs
des carburants en dessous les produits
nous allons baisser notre insu les
carburants les carburants c'est 80 % de
taxes les vlv par l'état nous les bété
il y aura des taxes mais vous ferez sans
misère de dépenses supplémentaires mais
j'ai vu on vous a vu aux commandes on a
vu vos résultats on avait notre
permettant aux ivoire avec un projet qui
n'est pas financé
le risque le risque dépendance que
madame le pen prétend créer vous le
financer comment par cotisation c'est
des entreprises qui vont payer c'est
l'impôt mettez la csg ses décodeurs
on ne sait pas aux forces économiques
l'europe à l'euro nissan pas elles ont
d'ailleurs supprimée de rachel monsieur
dupont-aignan avant le suivant la sortie
du lot pendant 2-3 ont supprimé les
régions qui sont des véritables qui sont
des usines à gaz qui dépense énormément
d'argent nous allons gérer mais
l'intercommunalité
regardez nous allons supprimer le nombre
de députés nous allons suffisait à
certains et ce que je peux reprendre la
main si vous aimez merci beaucoup et
nous ferons des économies de la sous les
troncs ci contre la fraude aussi sociale
monte elle madame montel vous êtes en à
moosch dans votre temps de parole
oui oui non mais attendez moi on me dit
dans mon oreillette que vous êtes en
avance en temps de parole j'aimerais
vous poser une question monsieur collet
en tant que macro nist sur ce plateau
emmanuel macron est-il libéral ou pas
c'est une crainte de certains électeurs
de gauche qui le jugent beaucoup trop
libérale vous vous répondez quoi je
pense que manuel macron à en matière de
macroéconomie la volonté effectivement
que nos entreprises et démarches pour se
battre que notre pays puisse exprimer
ses talents et de ce point de vue là on
peut considérer que l'inspiration
macroéconomique et libéral mais quand il
s'agit d'augmenter le salaire net de
protéger de façon plus juste en faisant
des retraites et de l'assurance chômage
un système universel en supprimant les
récits en faisant en sorte que conçoit
fonctionnaires du privé agriculteurs
artisans ou indépendants on est les
mêmes garanties de retraite et de
sécurité sociale
alors il prend
taj est effectivement libérée davantage
et protéger plus justement sont les deux
piliers sur lesquels est construite
vous dites libérales oui mais protecteur
aussi absolument absolument et c'est
tout à fait possible et c'est justement
cette synthèse qui nous manque depuis
des décennies chacun tous les cinq ans
tirant d'un côté ou tirant de l'autre et
finissant par fatiguer notre tissu
économique et social où les règles
changent sans arrêt alors mesdames en
thelle parle vous voulez réagir
peut-être oui le banquier macron n'est
pas libérale il est ultra libérale on
l'a vu notamment avec la loi
on l'a vu avec la loi elle comme riz
messieurs je lisais hier un article dans
valeurs actuelles qui nous explique que
la loi une connerie elle est par exemple
catastrophique au niveau des recours
pour les deux devant les prud'hommes 40%
de d'affaires enregistrée en moins aux
prud'hommes de lyon et aux prud'hommes
de paris
parce que la loi est comme riz à
complexifier énormément les dépôts de
dossiers puisque maintenant il faut
présenter de vous la faire comme une
céréale wahid comme certains le disent
oui donc emmanuel macron fera une loi
travail loi elle comme riz puissance 10
avant répondez quoi puissance 10 mais
non il faut effectivement une logique
qu'ils soient claires les rapports sur
le lieu de travail doivent être régis
par la loi dans les grandes lignes par
les accords de branche et accords
d'entreprise pour ce qui concerne leur
mise en oeuvre
c'est une volonté de redonner au
dialogue social dans l'entreprise une
véritable force est de ne pas faire des
salariés et de leurs employeurs
forcément des ennemis mais aussi des
gens qui collaborent dans un cadre
législatif précis
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous
d'abord je le lis moins valeurs
actuelles que vous mais le fait qu'il y
ait moins de recours aux prud'hommes ne
paraît pas une catastrophe nationale
dame madame monde celle dit que si
marine le pen était une présidente de la
république donc on supprime des échelons
territoriaux
on supprime les régions et c'est
emmanuel macron ferait quoi comment ils
voient les territoires alors les
territoires pour lui comme les individus
doivent s'émanciper pour pouvoir
participer au projet national et
apporter leurs particularités et leurs
atouts il a proposé comme simplification
que là où il ya métropole il n'y ait pas
département parce que c'est vrai qu'on
voit par exemple dans des situations
comme celle de lyon que c'est déjà le
cas c'est une simplification mais je
dois dire que supprimer
l'intercommunalité convoyait
énergie que au delà des clivages on est
capable de mettre dans les
intercommunalités pour mutualiser des
moyens au service des territoires
ça me paraît une ineptie contracyclique
total contre aux régions c'est notre
outil justement pour exister en matière
de formation d'investissement de
recherche au niveau européen
vous voulez affaiblir la france pour le
lavoir à votre main et omet au prétexte
de protéger la mettre sous cloche et la
faire dépérir au ban des nations
et vous voulez une france totalement
sous la tutelle de berlin et bruxelles
voilà ce que je veux une france en
compétition et qui soit capable de faire
valoir ses valeurs
il ya plusieurs sexuelle passe ou votre
soi disant protection nationale vous ne
protégerait pas les français vous ne
protégerait pas les traits fait le pari
que la loi est comme ricky est dans les
cartons de monsieur macron puissance 10
et qui sera d'ailleurs adopté par
ordonnance
elle sera pas adoptée par par
l'assemblée sera adoptée par l'ordre par
ordonnance
ce qui veut dire qu'on fera un passage
en force et bien cette loi elle comrie
lt régulera encore plus il y aura encore
plus de flexibilité pour les
travailleurs et au final ce que vous
voulez c'est fini d'en finir avec les cd
parce que c'est dans les cartons de
bruxelles tout ça voilà
et vous allez monsieur le chantier macro
carton et le banquier magasin vous dire
c'est que et raison d'un milliard
d'euros de formation c'est ça le vrai
avenir pour les salariés formation vous
ne protégerait pas l'industrie française
en distribuant des sur des roulettes sur
les parquets de la formation dans les
conseils les genoux c'est un échec total
c'est un échec total les politiques de
formation parce qu'elles ne sont pas
adaptés aux demandes des entreprises aux
besoins de nos entreprises
ça fait 30 ans que ça dure là la cour
des comptes a édité rapport sur rapport
en expliquant que tout ça et c'est en
supprimant que vous avez réglé pour eux
il faut que la formation professionnelle
reviennent à l'état
voilà il faut que ça change a pricé
jacobine alors mais vous devez rester
des collectivités locales si moi j'aime
beaucoup les communes j'aime beaucoup
les départements parce qu'en plus ils
ont une histoire sont des collectivités
territoriales qui sont en lien direct
avec les patries alex commune savent
très bien que leur avenir est dans
l'intérêt non prévus et le fait que vous
ayez si peu de responsabilités au niveau
des collectivités locales montre bien la
sagesse ne continuez pas du tout juste
il reste 5 minutes et je voudrais
aborder mais vraiment 40 secondes pour
l'art et pour l'autre une question la
sécurité
quels sont donc les propositions de
le pen pour la sécurité d'abord je note
il faut que les français soient
conscients que monsieur macron et
soutenu la plus aux élèves qui est une
organisation islamiste appelait à voter
et à appeler le dit monsieur mohamed
zaouche et monsieur mohamed saoud qui
est impérieuse verrai ce dossier en
marche
les résultats mis des chaînes sur
internet des photos de d'imams que
radicaliser un imam qui a radicalisé
l'image autrement de monsieur gauche et
de maltage mouchet du bataclan où il a
dû batailler en politique aux gens de
chez vous raconter mon run et les riches
je collais ce qui est le danger
aujourd'hui le danger aujourd'hui pour
les français c'est le fondamentalisme
islamiste et monsieur macro ne fera rien
alors on va les airs et les
communautarismes d'un motel laisse
répondre monsieur collet vous avez
trente secondes pour répondre et on
passe à la conclusion
l'accusation de communautarisme est un
mensonge éhonté rassembler les français
pour l'avenir c'est notre volonté pour
la sécurité création d'une police de
proximité du quotidien renforcement des
effectifs coordination du renseignement
pour lutter contre la menace terrorisme
et soutien à nos armées bien sûr que si
la france terrorisme international vous
n'êtes pas grâce à un fait je vous
propose donc de passer à la dernière
partie de cette émission la conclusion
[Musique]
et juste avant de passer donc à la
conclusion chacun de nos invités aura le
même temps de parole si ils le temps de
parole et est actuellement à égalité
madame montel est ce que vous êtes
candidate sur la 4e circonscription du
doubs où vous avez donc manqué de peu
l'élection il ya deux ans dans une
élection partielle
oui oui pourquoi on connaît pas pas plus
de candidats fn pour ces législatives
parce que nous sommes concentrés sur
l'élection présidentielle est pas mal il
ya des problèmes entre du tout dans le
font danser nous mettons tout notre
toute notre énergie dans cette élection
présidentielle voilà ce que nous voulons
c'est porter marine à l'elysée nos
petites personnes n'ont guère
d'importance
on parlera des législatives en temps et
en heure monsieur collègues comme je
disais vous êtes député sortant de
l'yonne vous avez poser votre
candidature à la candidature pour en
marche que ç'a l'air d'être compliqué
chez vous en ce moment si les décisions
qui sont pesées dans une commission
chacun a donné ses disponibilités
moi également je dois dire
qu'effectivement les destins personnels
ont peu d'importance mais pour ce qui
concerne en marche
on garde de l'énergie pour les
législatives et nos adversaires que nous
aurons battues seront donc épuisé c'est
ce que j'ai noté et enlever les eaux
vous êtes maman tels l assemblée
nationale vous allez dégager une
majorité comment nous allons dégager une
majorité parce que les français sont
cohérents et que quand ils auront choisi
un projet qui rassemble les français
pour leur avenir
ils donneront une majorité au président
de la république très bien donc vous
êtes actuellement on nous dit on dans
l'oreillette en régie vous êtes
actuellement à égalité donc une minute
pour vous madame montel pour terminer
mais je voudrais dire aux français et
aux françaises que
voilà où ils en reprennent pour cinq ans
avec bébé hollande ils sont conscients
ils ont marqué lors du premier tour de
cette élection présidentielle une
volonté de rupture avec le système est
la seule candidate qui leur offre cette
possibilité au deuxième tour c'est
marine le pen ce qui attend les français
si monsieur macron le banquier macron
venait à être élu président de la
république est absolument catastrophique
ce seront les politiques de monsieur
hollande démultiplier d'ailleurs tout
l'entourage de monsieur macron n'est
constituée que de vieux de la vieille de
ps2 de 2,2 de verre qui se recyclent de
gens de l'udi du modem qui se recyclent
autour de monsieur mac rond en espérant
pouvoir continuer à mener les politiques
totalement désastreuse impulsé
directement par l'union européenne vous
aurez avec monsieur macron une loi elle
comme riz adopté par ordonnance
puissance 10 avec une dérégulation une
flexibilité pour les travailleurs qui
sera total et puis ensuite monsieur
macron ne fera rien pour lutter contre
l'insécurité contre le fondamentalisme
islamiste
il ne fera rien non plus pour lutter
contre la directive des travailleurs
détachés qui aujourd'hui ruines des pans
entiers de notre industrie mais s'y est
collé une minute de conclusion bien
écouté et contrairement madame montel
moi je ne fais pas faire une diatribe
contre madame le pen mais présentait
l'espoir que représente le mouvement en
marche puisque apparemment madame honte
elle a du mal à faire des propositions
donc je ferai moi pour moi la
présentation de celle d' emmanuel macron
il s'agit de dépasser les clivages qui
ont donné une alternance mécanique dans
notre pays
rassembler les talents conjugués les
convictions pour quoi faire
pour affronter les défis du monde la
sécurité certes mais également le défi
écologique le défi énergétique le défi
numérique que nos territoires ruraux
comme dans nos villes on trouve les
moyens de mettre en avant les atouts de
la jeunesse se former investir être de
la compétition et non pas se retrancher
sur le banc de touche protéger pour ne
pas faire face à cette compétition la
france a les moyens
avec toutes celles et ceux qui la peuple
et qui veulent choisir l'avenir avec l
one hand macron de relever les défis de
l'avenir
et j'espère que le 7 mai au soir c'est
cela que nous commençons à faire alors
si ça vous a échappé dimanche prochain
donc on vote pour le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
merci madame merci monsieur d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
bon dimanche à tous
au revoir
[Musique]
pour certains